oggi vi parlerò di made in italy ma
partirà un po più da lontano
apple oggi è tra le aziende più
innovative al mondo e i numeri sulle
vendite e profitti ne testimoniano il
successo ma solo 15 anni fa quindi non
molto tempo fa era un'azienda in piena
crisi d'identità avendo perso la sua
leadership in quello che era il suo
settore chiave dei personal computer e
per il rilancio
la apple scommette su un altra industria
quella della musica nel 2001 quindi
arriva l'ipod un prodotto che per design
e perso superiorità delle
caratteristiche tecniche non poteva che
essere un successo
ebbene questo sono il grafico sulle
vendite dell'ipad
nei primi due anni dal lancio del
prodotto in realtà e ipod non registra
il successo sperato e solo a partire dal
2004 quando la apple infatti lancia la
piattaforma itunes dando vita quindi ad
un intero mercato di quella che poi è
diventata insomma la musica digitale che
l'ipod registra numeri interessanti fino
poi a dominare l'intero mercato
ora poi la apple come sapete ha
replicato questa strategia di successo
prima nel mercato degli smartphone con
l'iphone e poi in quello dei tablet con
l'ipad è la storia di successo della
apple è certamente legata al successo
delle sue innovazioni dei prodotti ma
ancor più a l'innovazione dell'intero
business model ovvero alla
riconfigurazione di a
delle proprie attività in modo da
fungere da connessione e interazione tra
quelli che sono i consumatori finali dei
propri prodotti e riproduttori esterni
di beni accessori quali sono ad esempio
appunto la musica digitale nel caso
dell'ipad e le applicazioni e contenuti
multimediali
nel caso degli altri prodotti iphone
ipad e vi starete chiedendo allora in
questo questo punto a quanto se e in che
modo insomma questo possa applicarsi al
contesto italiano del made in italy
ebbene pensate a quali sono i prodotti
che evocano rappresentano il made in
italy nel mondo
io ad esempio in mente abbiamo visto dal
pool prima alcune slide le auto sportive
le moto sportive o comunque prodotti dei
designer sono quelli più evocative della
nostra creatività
ebbene questi prodotti il loro valore va
molto al di là di quelle che sono le
semplici e caratteristiche tecniche e
ognuno di questi prodotti richiede il
coinvolgimento di diversi attori
specializzati e di numerosi beni
accessori che quindi ne accrescono il
valore e l'utilità anche emotiva se
volete
infatti nel caso della ducati che non
vende motociclette francamente ma
attraverso esse vende molto di più vende
passione vende emozioni per coloro che
si identificano nella particolare moto e
nel brand ducati è infatti la ducati lo
scrive sul proprio web la ducati produce
emozioni e la ducati come la apple a
metà degli anni 90 ha vissuto una
profonda crisi finanziaria che l'ha
portata quasi al fallimento come ne è
uscita reinventandosi trasformandosi da
azienda metalmeccanica puramente
qual'era a azienda di intrattenimento
come l'ha definita il nuovo
amministratore delegato costruita
intorno è per la community dei ducatisti
si è trasformata insomma in una
community platform quindi vede già un
parallelo
apple si è trasformata in una cosiddetta
market platform la ducati si è
trasformata in una community platform
pensate che la prima decisione che il
nuovo amministratore delegato dell'epoca
preso fu quella di costruire un museo
immaginate un azienda in crisi al
collasso sull'orlo del fallimento
arriva l'amministratore delegato
costruisce un museo il museo della moto
ma altre attività come queste come ad
esempio il raduno mondiale dei ducatisti
a misano piuttosto che l'apertura dei
negozi monomarca ducati o l'accesso al
paddock durante le corse del
motomondiale
sono tutte attività che hanno reso
possibile coinvolgere e mantenere attiva
la community dei ducatisti e questa
forza di entità della community
alla fine ha rafforzato il senso di
appartenenza alla stessa e attraverso
questo senso di appartenenza ne ha
accresciuto la customer experience è il
brand ducati e questi non sono valori di
marketing sono valori che poi si sono
prodotti si riproducono ogni giorno in
benefici economici per la ducati ma non
è il solo caso di trasformazione in
platform a di successo uno strano edra è
un'altra azienda italiana storica nel
settore dell'interior design toscana che
ha saputo reinventarsi e trasformarsi
appunto da azienda manifatturiera ad una
design platform dove la attività
centrale oggi è semplicemente quella di
scouting cioè di scoperta di giovani
design di talenti e selezione dei
progetti con un più alto potenziale che
poi possono essere messi in produzione
in scala in alcuni modelli è il prodotto
stesso che si fa piattaforma come il
caso ad esempio della campagna 500 wants
you dove la fiat ha coinvolto
direttamente il consumatore per
sviluppare cooperare quindi questo
motore nello sviluppo delle agli
allestimenti e degli accessori di quel
prototipo che poi
diventata la 500 che tutti noi oggi
conosciamo o nel caso anche dei gioielli
damiani e il brand a fungere da
piattaforma in questo caso quindi come
vedete ci sono già dei casi in italia di
successo che hanno in comune questa
trasformazione di del modello di
business in un modello a piattaforma e
quindi questi casi ci insegnano che
oltre l'innovazione a livello di
prodotto essere competitivi oggi vuol
dire reinventare rigenerare rinnovare il
proprio modello di business
quindi a questo punto quello che
dovreste chiedervi qual è il mio
platform model è davvero solido per
affrontare il futuro e le sfide
innovative che ci attendono
beh enzo ferrari soleva dire che la
macchina migliore è quella che ancora
doveva costruire e questa è una
filosofia quanto più attuale quasi oggi
perché ci ricorda che forse è arrogante
e anche miope pensare di affrontare il
futuro continuando ad applicare modelli
che hanno funzionato in passato ma che
possono appunto essere obsoleti per il
futuro il futuro passa attraverso una
continua rigenerazione in realtà di
questi modelli di business e la
trasformazione in uno dei modelli di
platform
grazie